pour le commun des mortels rien de plus
banal que de mettre des aliments dans un
panier d'épicerie
mais pas ici on n'a pas des choses à
manger on n'a pas de
vêtements lenny hernandez est arrivé au
canada du mexique comme réfugié
politique
son quotidien pourrait se résumer en un
mot sur vie mais avec tous les jours
toujours pour mes enfants
des histoires comme celle de lenny
chantal grenier en a entendu des
centaines travailleuse sociale dans un
centre pris une grande côte des neiges
elle est bénévole ici depuis des années
si mes tripes tous les jours sur sa
table alors cessé c'est ça c'est
agréable de voir les gens partir d'ici
avec un sourire de excusez-moi si mu de
nous dire chaleureusement on va passer
un noël ici peut-être le premier noël à
montréal mais ça votre noël chaleureux
des magasins partage où les denrées sont
vendus à un prix symbolique il y en a
dans 17 quartiers de montréal
ils sont ouverts une fois par année la
semaine avant noël
c'est là que près de 6000 familles
feront leur épicerie défaite après une
rupture et je connais un peu ce que
c'était la pauvreté c'était il ya vingt
ans et cette expérience personnelle a
donné l'idée à sylvie rochette de fonder
ses épiceries éphémère qui avec les
années sont de plus en plus nécessaire
il ya des nouveaux
les gens qui sont sur le marché du
travail salar il travaille 40 heures par
semaine au salaire minimum vivent sous
le seuil de la pauvreté
c'est un 14 le nombre de personnes qui
ont recours à des banques alimentaires
s'accroît constamment
c'est en moyenne plus de 150000
montréalais par mois émilie dubreuil
radio canada mon frère